my head cut off unfortunately I'm trying
to slow I know Otto Delaney too much fat
now your heads perfect I wouldn't change
a thing about your head Arianna thank
you they're gonna make that sexual no
they won't
your people my people your people your
people who make that sexual
I have one-on-one we camera that's my
big thing what's that mean talking just
to the camera
that means primarily yeah you know feel
like I'm talking to each other we don't
talk to each other this is what
youtubers do who really make it in the
world they only talk to you you're alone
in the room this is not meant for
thousands of people to view just you
what about us sitting here well that we
have to talk to each other like a
peripherals game welcome to YouTube
Ariana this is the way it works around
here now a funny car commercial from the
channel car surgeon my name's Ariana oh
yeah her name is Ariana female /
comedian oh my you got better better
come on that's not too bad it's not bad
it's not I've been worse it's been a
long haul this weekend alright big
enough smoke that comes up big bill
hell's car you're gonna find a bar that
big bill you can kiss my ass
but you're such a stupid [ __ ] no
fall for this [ __ ] guarantee if you
want a better deal shove it up
almost challenge challenge history how
does it work ooh six feet of the air
straight up and nothing right you get no
don't wait go delay will rip your nuts
off [ __ ] as the minute after you win
us a chance better not bomb sir you're a
dead [ __ ] go to hell bill hell's
car bomb or she'll be an exclusive home
of the meanest sons of [ __ ]
understand their wall guarantee lit
financers what happens in Maryland well
that wasn't a real car come early not I
wish it was I wish that was real this
was updated in 2008 it's updated 2008 it
was originally made in like 78 uh was it
really originally me oh yeah you're
saying you think you probably took a
real commercial yeah and then and then
doesn't card I mean I don't know what
how old those cars seemed I find it very
impressive Ariana you look at me I can
feel it in my peripheral used to it
think about it
I know it's an awareness thing Jonah's a
real life I'm used to actually looking
at people it's the way real people
communicate not on the internet though I
don't know what yeah now it's cars are
but I believe us before 2008 I'm pretty
sure was - I meant the the year the
video was uploaded not yeah not another
year was just made but thank you for
that um I love videos like this videos
that can do spoofs of like old time on
Netflix right now there's this movie
that Johnny Depp stars in as Donald
Trump the art of the deal I've been
seeing Funny or Die yeah exactly and is
it really have you seen him peel off his
face
yeah what it's a it's a funnier guy like
Instagram video of him looking in the
mirror Oh Donald Trump
faith off well the way it was shot is
really
brilliant like it feels like legit 80s
like straight to DVD sales video doing
this it's admirable to capture a
different time
even the sound obviously he did the
voice work with the swearing and all
that stuff and the text very impressive
I don't know how someone begins to do
that so I wish I could've given you this
compliment like almost 10 years ago
however it's here now bring it back you
look at each other you know sometimes
you know I'm not gonna do it really I
was already told not to Hey hmm you
shouldn't just listen to what people
tell you um you are directing this and
you've hired me so I'm going to look in
the camera director is a Latin word for
dictatorship David Ayer one on lemon
camera I'm not gonna look at you I said
treat the camera primarily oh not only
hey do you have a dream car no you don't
have a dream car
no okay if I had too often if I was to
present you like a whole bunch of cars
right okay fine maybe g-wagen a g-wagen
or they're so douchey Wow I like that do
you care what kind of car a guy drives
know if it's like a really old car was
it heavier in the room yeah a Toyota
Corolla that was like my family's
favorite car we had one for 13 years so
you can't try to throw that on me it was
my dad's favorite car
you heard it boys with their
two-year-old girl if you're someone who
likes subscription services you know
that's it you know I wake up with 9
emails a day
me too Quorra digest what's up the daily
skin Rove all color pop which is like
Kylie Jenner's lip kit but much cheaper
yahoo entertainment news you hear about
Justin Bieber and Selena Gomez this
morning well because of baby Richie
Nicole Richie's little sister what's her
name Jane or something I don't know not
Jane no one named Jane now she's 17 he's
22
yeah but Selena revealed that Bieber
cheated on
yeah and then we kind of alluded that
she might have cheated without One
Direction guy Dana I keep up with you I
think us great if youtubers rawness this
is what you get
following celebrity gossip I don't know
what else goes on well I'm surprised you
do you follow it I'm pretty positive guy
but I love a good gossip stories
subscribe to the real rejects please I
need it is what I'm trying to tell you
need life does depend I depend on it it
who Arianna is funny woman better tonic
honey if you guys are in LA she's gonna
be at the Comedy Store in the ice pick
store know the ice house okay story yeah
I'll be promoting I think the ice house
um what are the dates August 24th is the
Comedy Store August 28th is ice house
Pasadena well you see a few thousand
people are going to watch this video so
no one shows up Ariana that's
embarrassing all my parents go to all my
shows
so I guess already um and that's why I
go to your shows why because they help
provide me with some food when I am
laughing so first with some food
Oh cuz my parents feed you yeah they pay
for me all the time they don't ever let
me pay for much they're really grateful
when people come to see me ah